[Music]
Steve YouTube engineer flew to LA to
talk to us about awareness with HDR on
YouTube problem is when he came and we
filmed we found it difficult to
articulate why it's so important in
editing I try to put it together and
this is the best solution I just need to
tell you straight up
what HDR is and why it's important on
YouTube each year is the new standard of
image quality that's coming up right now
just like how our screens of all from
standard to HD 4k your phones tablets
and TVs are evolving as well but not in
resolution instead brightness and color
finally getting it bright and it's rich
full of colors of the IMAX movie screen
might be surprised to learn this but
your screen that you're watching this
right now it's not that bright here look
at this light look at it it's it's not
that hard but if you are really here
your eyes would squint because it's so
freakin bright now HDR if you're not
careful your phone and TV will actually
make you experience the real brightness
as if you're here looking at a light if
you have a normal screen that's not HCR
you actually only get 50% of all the
colors in the real world because
theaters can display 85% of the colors
you see in the real world
whereas rec.709 about 50% for those
colors on this now half the colors I
have so somebody went around measured
everything flowers street signs
everything you see on a normal basis and
that's called pointers gamma HD are
technically specified up to ninety-nine
point seven percent of that but for
complicated science of vision reasons
that's actually not really practical to
get to anytime soon but do you need more
brightness and more colors out of all
the strange inventions from around the
world that could send to us I think
today we've received one of the weirdest
these job' punching gloves now these are
extendable and apparently they're so
cool and you're going to get have such
an intense fight with them that you're
going to need a wristband to strap your
wrist now let's see how durable they are
[Music]
[Music]
you watch that whole segment without any
audio but you know what
Carmichael's such a good editor and he
has so little time before this video
comes out that he's going to set it to
some nice music for you so yeah I guess
these are just prototypes which only
leads me to assume that the real ones
that they'll be selling later this fall
will be a lot easier to break I'm
excited for HTR because that's a creator
I can make my images more painterly and
I can know for sure that you're going to
see it exactly the way I wanted you to
see them now the main reason why Steve
the YouTube engineer showed up is to
build awareness of HTR on YouTube
features have already been rolled out on
you yet how long have anything it rolled
out with November of last year so any
month and if you just expose properly
like you would for SDR then most of the
workflow stays the same and everyone
watching is a creator I do want to break
down hopefully quickly and correctly six
key bullet points on how to make HDR
video one you need a camera with a
minimum of ten stops of dynamic range -
you need ten bit color 3 don't over
expose your video it's going to be that
right for you're going to need a record
in a log or raw mode 5 your editing
doesn't change your finalizing does your
color correction and you're exporting
color in HDR video on an HDR screen
you're done coloring you're going to
need to export it in a specific HDR
codec finally 6 when you upload the
YouTube the site will recognize that
your video is an HDR file and if your
audience is watching it on an HDR phone
or whatever it will go oh an HDR screen
the problem
the workflow of creating it the tooling
involved is just so complicated right or
at least right now windows actually
supports HDR if you plug your windows
Creator update into a HDR monitor or HDR
television it's going to suck a lot when
there's not enough HDR content out there
for you to take advantage of on your
brand-new super expensive screen and so
we'd expect to see this on pretty much
every phone over the coming month
like it's not very bright where it's
here it pops it's an actual pure white
that is a difference though right in the
camera in the camera okay okay good the
$35,000 pomander that most HP our comms
are graded on that said that price tag
sounds huge but we've got one in space
LA and space New York and I think we're
adding one to space London and maybe
space Paris you all can just go in there
and you just do that last mastering step
in that room one one day it takes a
couple hours and then you've got HDR
masters on the same displays that they
use to master HDR movies I'm wearing a
white shirt today because it represents
the absence of design you know how we
made these limited edition corridor hats
well Sam gorski's cooked up another hot
and ready corridor digital special
edition t-shirt it's going to be
available next week so keep your eyes
open for it and also keep your eyes open
for clowns